we should be doing this outside
good afternoon everyone i just visited a
vaccination
clinic in virginia at the virginia
theological seminary in alexandria
virginia
the seminary and other houses of worship
in the area are
partnering with the community health
centers
to offer vaccinations and vaccination
sites
they're seeing these kinds of
partnerships we're and not just there
but we're seeing them all over the
country
people are coming together across
different faiths to serve those
most in need with special focus on
vaccinating seniors
from all races backgrounds and walks of
life
it's an example of america at its finest
and they're all meeting what pope
francis calls the moral obligation
get vaccinated something which can he
went on to say
can save your life and the lives of
others
and i was at the seminary clinic to mark
an important milestone as well
yesterday we crossed 150 million
shots in 75 days the first 75 days of my
administration
on our way to hitting our goal of 200
million shots
by the 100th day in office that of
course is the new goal
i said after passing the original mark
of 100 million shots in my first hundred
days
doing that in just 58 days at the time
some said 100 million shots was too
ambitious
and then they said it wasn't ambitious
enough well we got to keep moving if we
could raise it up higher i'd do that as
well but we know
we know we have to do we have to ramp up
a whole government approach
that rallies the whole country and puts
us on a war footing to truly beat this
virus
and that's what we've been doing getting
enough vaccine supply
mobilizing more vaccinators creating
more places to get vaccinated
and we're now administering an average
of 3 million shots per day
over 20 million shots a week on saturday
alone
we reported more than 4 million shots
were administered
we're the first country to administer
150 million shots in the first country
to fully vaccinate over 62 million
people
but here's the deal i promise an update
to the american people every 50
millionth shot
and i'm already back to update you a
little over two weeks two and a half
weeks later
i promise in the beginning that i'd
always give you the straight scoop
straight from the shoulder
the good and the bad well here's the
truth
the good news is we're on track to beat
our goal of 200 million shots in the
first hundred days
more than 75 percent of the people
over the age of 65 have gotten shots
up from eight percent when we took
office
that's a dramatic turnaround and
critical
because seniors account for eighty
percent of all
cover deaths to help support my goal of
safely opening the majority of k-8
schools by my 100th day in office
i directed states in early march
to make educators and children child
care workers
eligible for vaccines and to get a goal
of getting all who wanted the
vaccination
to be able to have one and to do it in
the month of march
i'm pleased to report according to cdc
estimates over 80 percent of teachers
school
chat school staff and child care workers
received at least one shot by the end of
march
that's great progress protecting our
educators our essential workers
and because our vaccine program is an
overdrive
for making it easier to get a
vaccination shot
last week i announced that by april 19th
of this month
90 of all americans will be within
five miles of a vaccination site
and further good news is that we're
getting more and more data
on just how effective the vaccines are
dr fauci recently cited two studies from
the new england journal of medicine
that found fully vaccinated care workers
health care workers
on the front lines had extremely low
infection rates
less than two tenths of one percent
compared to unvaccinated health care
workers who had considerably higher
infection rates
so we're making incredible progress
there's a lot of good news but there's
also some bad news
new new variants of the virus
are spreading and they're moving quickly
cases are going back up hospitalizations
are no longer declining
while deaths are still down way down
from january
they're going up in some places so you
might ask
everybody's asking what does that mean i
understand that people may find it
confusing
that the vaccination program is saving
tens of thousands of lives but the
pandemic remains dangerous
let me explain it in a single word time
time even moving at the record speed
removing that we're not
even halfway through vaccinating over
300 million americans
this is going to take time remember
for a two dose vaccine it takes
weeks from the time you get your first
one until you're able to get your
second shot which makes you fully
protected
if you get your first shot next week in
mid april
you won't be fully protected until until
may late may
if you get your first shot in midway you
aren't fully protected until late june
so look now on the one hand
june isn't that far away given how long
this has been going on
but it isn't here yet either so
the virus is spreading because we have
too many people
who've seen the end in sight think we're
at the finish line already
let me be deadly earnest with you we
aren't
at the finish line we still have a lot
of work to do
we're still in a life and death race
against this virus
until we get more people vaccinated we
need everyone to wash their hands
socially distance and mask up in a
recommended mass from the cdc
think about it this way better times are
ahead
as i said before we can have a safe
happy fourth of july
with your family and your friends and
small groups in your backyard
the real question is how much death
disease and misery
are we're going to see between now and
then
in january just the month of january we
lost
95 747
excuse me 95 774 americans
in march that was 37
172 americans all
told you know i keep doing this i know
but i carry this card every day with my
schedule on it
and the back i have a covet update the
total number of deaths in the united
states to date
is 554 thousand
64 dead
that's lives that have been lost
what we do now is going to determine how
many people will
will save or lose in the month of april
and may and june
before we get to july 4th so please
until we're further along in this
accelerating
successful but still growing vaccination
effort
please wash your hands practice social
distancing
wear a mask as recommended by the cdc
get vaccinated when it's your turn
while i'm asking americans the american
people to do their jobs
here's what i'm doing we first started
our vaccination program
the real question is how quickly we can
get shots in people's arms
well by the end of may the vast majority
of dull americans
will have gotten at least their first
shot
that success that success is going to
save lives
and get this country back to normal
sooner
but it's not enough on march the 11th
i announced that i was opening up all
vaccination sites
to all adults by may 1st
many governors democrats and republicans
responded and decided to beat that date
which was good
thanks to their hard work and the hard
work of the american people
and the hard work of my team i'm
announcing today that we're moving that
date up from
may 1st to april 19th nationwide
that means by no later than april 19th
in every part of this country every
adult
over the age of 18 18 or older will be
eligible to be vaccinated
no more confusing rules no more
confusing restrictions
my message today is a simple one many
states have already opened up to all
adults
but beginning april 19th every adult
in every state every adult in this
country is eligible to get in line
to get a covert vaccination
and today in advance of that new
national
full eligibility date i want to make a
direct appeal to our seniors
and everyone who cares about them while
we have made incredible progress
vaccinating three-quarters of our
seniors and putting vaccination sites
within
five miles of 90 of the public
it still isn't enough it's simple
seniors it's time for you to get
vaccinated
now get vaccinated now
to make it easier my administration is
sending aid to community groups
to drive seniors to vaccination sites
we're incredibly grateful to all the
volunteers houses of worship
and civic groups that are helping us in
this effort
this is america we take care of one
another
we have to keep it up as we ask seniors
to sign up for their shots
now i also have a message of people
under 65.
if you know someone over 65 who has not
gotten this life-saving vaccine
call them now work with them to get
their shots
this week or next pick them up drive
them
it can be your parents your grandparents
your aunt uncle your neighbors
and finally even after you open up
vaccinations to all adults
and put a site within five miles of 90
of the public
we know there are many people who still
struggle to get access to a shot
we know that there are a number of
seniors and people with disabilities
and people in many communities of color
who may
be isolated and lack access to
transportation
that's why we're ramping up
transportation to vaccination centers
and deploying more
mobile units and pop-up clinics from the
places close to where people live
that's why we're working with
faith-based organizations and other
community groups
toast vaccination clinics sign people up
for appointments
get help help them get those
appointments
that's why we're sending even more
vaccines to community health centers
like the one i was today
that all together served nearly 30
million americans like the ones i
visited today
two-thirds of the patients at community
health centers live
at or below the poverty level 60 percent
are racial and ethnic minorities
to reach them we're investing nearly 10
billion dollars to expand testing
treatment and vaccinations for the
hardest hit
yet most underserved communities
let me close with this we vaccinated
more people than any other nation on
earth
the vaccines have proven to be safe and
effective
that should give us real hope but we
can't let it
we can't let it make us complacent
despite the progress we're making as a
nation
i want every american to know in no
uncertain terms
that this fight isn't over
this progress we've worked so hard to
achieve can be reversed
now is not the time to let down
now is not the time to celebrate it's
time to do what we do best as a country
do our duty our jobs taking care of one
another
and we can and will do this but we
can't let up now my hope is
before the summer's over i'm talking to
you all about how we have even
access to more vaccines than we need
to take care of every american and we're
helping other poor countries
countries around the world that don't
have the money the time the expertise
because until this vaccine is available
to the world
and we're beating back the
black sea the virus in other countries
we're not really completely safe
so we've made great progress
i'm still looking forward to the
prospect if we keep the pace we're on
and we listen to one another
take the precautions i talked about that
you'd be able to have
a fourth of july an independence day
on july the 4th as i defined about
three weeks ago i want to have an
independence day in independence from
the
covet so you're able to get in the
backyard with a small group of people of
friends and neighbors and celebrate
independence day because you've been
vaccinated
because you're safe because you're in a
clear
may god bless you all and may god
protect our troops thank you so much for
listening
thank you for going mr president indiana
uh
i'll report on that later do you think
the masters golf tournament should be
moved out of georgia
i think that's up to the masters
look
you know um
it is reassuring to see that
uh for-profit operations and businesses
are speaking up about how
these new jim crow laws are just
antithetical to who we are there's
another side to it too
the other side to it too is when they in
fact move out of georgia
the people who need to help the most
people who are making
hourly wages sometimes get hurt the most
i think it's a very tough decision for a
corporation to make
or a group to make but i respect them
when they make that judgment
and i support whatever judgment they
make but it's
the best way to deal with this is for
georgia and other states to smarten up
stop it stop it
stop killing people
despite your personal appeal now there
are many americans who are very
reluctant to take the vaccine especially
in red states
why the white house hasn't used a more
forceful campaign
like advertisement on television for
example
to convince americans to take that
medicine so we can do it
we are doing that and by the way the
number of people are reluctant to take
it
continues to diminish continues to
diminish across the country
as they see their neighbors particularly
in communities that have been
very now there's a different group of
people there's a group of people
who've been reluctant because of past
how can i say it past wrongs that have
been done to them
experimentation not sure that they're
being told the truth etc
but then there's another group it seems
to me to be uh
i probably shouldn't characterize it but
mitch mcconnell keeps speaking to them
which i give him credit for saying the
idea he said the polling data shows
republican men
particularly young men don't think they
should have to take the vaccine
it's their patriotic right not to do it
the freedom to choose
and he's saying no no take the vaccine
take the vaccine and i'll add a phrase
he didn't but i think he believes
it's the patriotic responsibility you
have last question
have you spoken to the federal reserve
chairman jay powell yet
i have not
i i am not uh look i think the the
federal reserve was an independent
operation
and starting off my presidency i want to
be real clear
that i'm not going to do the kinds of
things that have been done in the last
administration
either talking to the attorney general
about who he's going to prosecute or not
prosecute
and under what circumstances or the fed
telling them what they should and should
do even though that wouldn't be the
basis upon which i'd be talking to him
so i've been very fastidious about not
talking to them but i do talk
to the secretary of treasury thank you
all very much
mr president you mentioned 554 064
american dead from cobia 19 a lot of
families want to know
how this happened how it got here have
you had a chance to
speak to any of your international
partners any of the president
when we can go way back with if you had
a chance to ask him if
these reports are true that china maybe
misled the world at the beginning
no i i have not had that conversation
with president xi
thank you